I'm Patrick baby of your host evalute
aiming weekly and I got a question for
you did you ever call into a love line
and dedicate a love song to somebody you
know you did you know you did you see in
the west coast in the LA area we have a
radio station called coast 103.5 and
there would be love song dedications at
night and I was thinking what would it
sound like if there was a dedication you
know love your radio station where you
can dedicate love songs to entrepreneurs
out there what would it sound like and I
said it's probably gonna go something
like this so join us and tell us that
this is kind of what it sounds like
all right so Mario where are you
coasting tonight it's a beautiful place
and Marie who's on your mind tonight
just working Sarge great ideas very
ambitious but they just you know they
need the right people to take their
business to another level pretty painful
I'm being lonely oh yeah and what would
you say to them if a lonely entrepreneur
is driving today what would you tell
them or her no I'll tell them not to
lose hope and you're looking for someone
that really has great ideas - give me a
call you can work together to change the
world you know I feel your pain Mario
and if you could dedicate any sunk to
them what would it be
you chose to all the lonely
entrepreneurs that are out there
listening getting you driving and you
feel the pain that mario has call us
tonight at 1-800 coast 103.5 and with
that being said let's listen to boy
Orbison's only
I think would go something like that
that's what I think would sound you know
why because there's a lot of
entrepreneurs out there that are lonely
you know when you start your business
you are going to be lonely for a period
you may have a great idea maybe doing
something and it's a great business
you're excited about it but your mom got
friend family no one supports everybody
thinks you're not they think you're
crazy to have started your own business
you should have a job what are you doin
leaving your job or even thinking about
doing something after five o'clock or
starting a gig you are out of your mind
and eventually what happens when your
only entrepreneur you're all by yourself
eventually eventually when you recruit
that partner of yours that running mate
of yours that leader of yours that sees
the vision that gets the idea just as
big as you
it changes the face of your business
overnight and the question becomes how
to start a movement there's a video out
there online on YouTube that has over 11
million views at this time and a TEDx
speaker took that video and explained
how to start a movement and I thought it
was the best explanation on how all
movements get started including those
who start their own businesses so watch
this video from TEDx so ladies and
gentlemen at Ted we talk a lot about
leadership and how to make a movement so
let's watch a movement happen start to
finish in under three minutes and
dissect some lessons from it first of
course you know a leader needs the guts
to stand out and be ridiculed but what
he's doing is so easy to follow so
here's his first follower with a crucial
role he's going to show everyone else
how to follow now notice that the leader
embraces him as an equal so now it's not
about the leader anymore it's about them
plural now there he is calling to his
friends if you notice that the first
follower is actually an underestimated
form of leadership in itself takes guts
to stand out like that the first
follower is what transforms a lone nut
into a leader
and here comes a second follower now
it's not a lone nut it's not two nuts
three is a crowd and the crowd is news
so a movement must be public it's
important to show not just the leader
but the followers because you find that
new followers emulate the followers not
the leader now here come two more people
and immediately after three more people
now we've got momentum this is the
tipping point now we've got a movement
so notice that as more people join in
it's less risky so those that were
sitting on the fence before now have no
reason not to they won't stand out they
won't be ridiculed but they will be part
of the in-crowd if they hurry so over
the next minute you'll see all of the
those that prefer to stick with the
crowd because eventually they would be
ridiculed for not joining in and that's
how you make a movement but let's recap
some lessons from this so first if you
are the type like the shirtless dancing
guy that is standing alone remember the
importance of nurturing your first few
followers as equals so it's clearly
about the movement not you okay but we
might have missed the real lesson here
the biggest lesson if you noticed did
you catch it is that leadership is
over-glorified that yes it was the
shirtless guy was first and he'll get
all the credit
but it was really the first follower
that transformed the lone nut into a
leader so as we're told that we should
all be leaders that would be really
ineffective if you really care about
starting a movement have the courage to
follow and show others how to follow and
when you find a lone nut doing something
great have the guts to be the first one
to stand up and join in and what a
perfect place to do that at Ted thanks